et on commence par le jaguar un être
solitaire d'Amérique du Sud qui aime
passer sa vie tranquille à la fraîche
détendue à prendre des bains de soleil
en tête à tête avec lui-même a grimper
aussi aux arbres pour pouvoir réfléchir
au sens de la vie et profiter du
panorama mais aussi à chasser des
caïmans pour le plaisir de les tuer bref
un vrai mal Alpha qui se la joue solo
toute l'année exception faite de la
saison des amours où il peut alors
s'accoupler plus de 100 fois par jour
j'étais sur le retilman
[Rires]
moi j'avais mon grand-père Lucien qui
est mort à 75 ans à l'hôpital donc
j'étais descendu de Paris pour aller
voir ses dépouilles sur le lit et j'ai
demandé à l'infirmier qui s'occupait de
lui j'espère qu'il a pas trop souffert
il m'a dit vous inquiétez pas il a baisé
toutes ses voisines de chambre
je croyais pas que le wokisme ça
existait je pensais que c'était un
fantasme de cnews et de valeurs
actuelles je le dis sans agressivité et
en réalité je découvre que c'est la
vérité que il y a vraiment des militants
violents qui veulent censurer un livre
qui menace qui injurie qui ne veulent
pas de conversation sur un sujet qui est
pourtant important qui est les relations
entre hommes et femmes qu'est-ce qu'il y
a qu'est-ce qu'il y a quel est votre
prénom mais juste pour savoir Ilona
alors qu'est-ce que vous disiez par
rapport au gros mots et aux onomatopées
dites-moi non non mais on peut le dire
et quel est votre prénom vous Céline
qu'est-ce que ça disait dites-nous
dites-nous allez-y mais on peut tout
dire non et après tu arrives
et je peux vous dire que les petites
filles de 8 9 ans
elle se gênait pas pour pour avoir des
rapports assez sexués elle jouait à ça
entre Ken et mardi il y avait un jeu
duquel on parlait jamais c'est faire des
bébés
[Musique]
trouver le mari de la Barbie
vous parliez de garçon ah vous parlez en
fillette de Django comme Django
Reinhardt en fait exactement exactement
bon et alors le garçon et alors
dès que je rencontre une femme je
l'imagine en train de faire l'amour
c'est la vérité de l'homme quand on ne
vous touche pas c'est uniquement parce
que la loi l'interdit pourquoi nous ne
sommes pas des monstres c'est un miracle
quotidien que davantage de femmes ne
soient pas victime d'agression sexuelle
l'immense majorité des hommes se
contiennent tout le temps voilà pourquoi
nous soupirons il est effrayant de se
retenir toute la journée de sauter sur
les femmes je vous assure moi je partage
pas du tout ce que vous dites
qui ne sert pas
nous nous adressons à tous les garçons
qui regardent cette vidéo voilà
reproducteurs et Rotter lors d'un voyage
en Europe elle tombe sur une poupée qui
s'appelle Lili qui a une poupée
allemande
alors Lily c'est pas du tout un jouet
elle est liée au magazine built qui est
un tableau idéalement qui existe encore
et c'est plutôt une sorte de cadeaux
qu'on s'offre avec parfois un petit
sous-entendu un tout petit peu grivois
le seul moment où un hétérosexuel peut
s'exprimer sincèrement devant une femme
c'est dans les minutes qui suivent son
éjaculation le reste du baratin pour
voir vos seins mais c'est
du c'est du un peu du cynisme vous
comprenez que c'est oui je suis d'accord
ça part de là et ensuite ça va vers
comment on fait pour établir un lien
voilà et alors romantique et je voulais
vous montrer question importante c'est
pas que faire l'amour c'est de s'aimer
il y aurait des hommes qui achèteraient
la poupée à leur date juste avant
d'aller en rendez-vous un petit peu pour
leur signifier leur intention de de
coucher avec
du temps
on est quand même
et vous rapprocher
là c'est pour le cadrage n'ayez pas peur
je vais me mettre l'absence vous êtes
toujours comme ça ou seulement quand il
y a une caméra de télévision
maison je peux merci est-ce que vous
avez une réputation à soutenir ou un
tempérament insatisfaire la tempérament
satisfaire est beaucoup plus valable
réputation je dois dire que vous y
employez depuis des années vous venez de
faire un smack à cette jeune dame du
public non
sur la joue ah je crois que c'était un
sport qui croyait encore 1990
tout va bien vous savez qu'on a une
petite tradition dans l'émission
de tirer un alors
[Rires]
le zapping pour assurer les plus
conservateurs Mattel va envoyer un
message très clair aux parents
dès sa première pub le ton est donné
oui Barbie peut sembler frivole coquette
mais dans un seul but accéder au mariage
dans les supermarchés c'est beaucoup
plus facile
on trouve tout ce qu'on veut tous les
étages on trouvait le rayon nuptial si
on veut vraiment se marier
il y a le rayon bricolage
on est à l'amateur douteux je pense que
c'est pas facile pour un homme de son
âge qui était une super peur de la télé
elle vous parle à vous vous allez y
arriver toi là-bas
ça va être dans pas longtemps je vais
réussir à finir oui foutez-lui la paix
parce que vous êtes misogyne vous aussi
Sonia et donc faire ce chemin d'être le
partenaire d'une femme qui est la chef
de son émission ça n'est pas si facile
et c'est un vrai signe d'intelligence
quatre bonnes réponses pour Aymeric
avoir un trou sous le nez être gros
mangeur et buveur c'est ça
peut faire du bien à des téléspectateurs
vous voyez de s'autoriser à parler
mais le droit aussi de
pardon
d'exister de vivre
est-ce qu'il m'arrive des choses bien
je vous rappelle que cette jeune
personne a 17 ans qu'elle nous a été
confiée par ses parents et qu'elle est
pensionnaires lunettes noires cigare au
bec le style du tronc à 80 ans le
chanteur entretient sa légende un
artiste devenu culte oui c'est un
provocateur c'est du cœur
qu'il est toujours cool avec son cigare
c'est de la joie de vivre au cinéma
comme en chanson Jacques Dutronc imprime
sa marque un dilettante à qui tourne ici
ça vous dérange pas
la timidité est une forme de politesse
estime aussi ce jeune homme de 80 ans de
la télévision Jacques Dutronc a aussi
dit on ne peut pas la regarder quand on
est debout on ne la regarde pas et quand
on est assis on s'endort